Welcome to the Khan Academy
we are honored that you have joined us
and what I hope to do is just give you a walk through
to think about how you might want to use the site.
So, first of all you might know exactly what
you want to learn about, you might say wait
I kind of wonder what a derivative is.
So you can do a search right over there
and there all sorts of exercises and videos
that deal with derivatives. For example,
you could go to the derivative intuition
exercise and you would see this thing
right over here which makes you think about
well what's the slope of the tangent line
at any of these points? And when you do it,
you're essentially plotting, plotting,
the derivative. Or you might say, well no,
I actually want, I actually want an explanation
of what a derivative is. Maybe you've already done
the derivative module. So, you might want
to look at a calculus proof or look at some
type of what a partial derivative might be.
And you click there and you would actually go
to the video. So, that's if you kind of know